[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
76 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am good.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
am very happy to be
back to San Francisco with
nice weather and everything
after a pretty awesome
week in New York.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, very nice.
Sounds like you had a little
bit of fun over there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I'm very
excited to be talking again
about Kubernetes.
Last week we had Chen
Goldberg from GKE talking
about why Container Engine is
open source and the difference
between Container
Engine and Kubernetes.
And this week we have Daniel
Smith, a software engineer
working in the
Kubernetes team to talk
about all the cool
new things that
come in with Kubernetes 1.6,
which came out not that long
ago.
MARK MANDEL: No, it
was several weeks ago.
Yeah, basically Daniel and I
nerd out for about 20 minutes
on Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and I tried
to understand some
of the things.
I use Kubernetes,
but I keep it very--
the basics.
If you're interested in
the really newest things,
like deep, deep
technical topics,
this episode is
going to be for you.
I'm sure you will enjoy it.
And then at the end,
we have a question
of the week, which is cool.
What do you do when you create
a Google Cloud Platform project?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, what
are the first things?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yep, personally--
so we will answer them
personally because we actually
don't agree.
But whatever.
MARK MANDEL: That's good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll
talk about that at the end.
But before that, we have
the cool things of the week.
And the first one is
about this new program.
It's called Cloud OnBoard.
Basically it's a
full training event
that is going to be happening
all around the world.
For now it's been announced
the dates and places
for North America.
So we'll have a link
in the show notes.
And I think that
there's a bunch of them.
I think I saw Austin--
MARK MANDEL: We've got
Dallas, Austin, and Toronto.
There should be more
coming I expect.
There is 12 cities
in US and Canada.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
Chicago, Vancouver, San
Francisco, LA, Seattle,
Atlanta, Boston, Washington,
DC, and New York City.
So a bunch of them.
And even better than that,
there's actually also
more events on this type.
So you can go and learn more
about Google Cloud Platform
all around the world.
So I know that I'll
be attending one in--
actually I'm going to ask
Mark to say the capital--
MARK MANDEL: [SIGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --of Argentina.
MARK MANDEL: I
massacred this before.
Buenos Air-es?
No, Buenos Arr-es.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Buenos Aires.
That's very good.
There you go.
So Buenos Aires will
be one of those places.
But I'm sure there
will be many more we'll
be announcing something soon.
So just listen to the podcast,
and we'll let you know.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, a free
full day of training programs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
they're really cool.
So I'm pretty
excited about those.
The second cool
thing of the week
is a very cool
thing of the week.
It's IPv6.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, so we've
got IPv6 finally supported.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yay.
MARK MANDEL: Well, we have beta.
It's in beta.
IPv6 termination for HTTPS
load balancing, SSL proxying,
and TCP proxy load balancing.
So if you have
IPv6 needs, we are
able to provide those for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, because
I think that this year is
the last year.
This year is the year
of Linux on the desktop
and the year we run
out of IPv4 addresses.
I think this is the same year.
MARK MANDEL: Linux on the
desktop is coming soon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Absolutely.
So yeah, if you want to use
IPv6, which I definitely
recommend, there's
actually a couple
of conferences that have already
moved completely to IPv6.
[INAUDIBLE] is one of them.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Kind of cool.
It forces you to update a
lot of different things.
But yeah, if you want
to use it, check it out.
We'll have a link
in the show notes.
And then the last cool thing
of the week comes from Mete
Atamel, who is a
developer advocate,
Google Cloud Platform
specialized in .NET
technologies.
And he's based in London
if I remember correctly.
And he wrote a really
cool blog post on gRPC,
specifically from
the point of view
of everybody says that
gRPC is really good to have
interoperation or support
to have multiple programming
languages in the same system.
Is that actually true?
So he talks about how to
make something that you
have a server written in Java.
And the client is actually
written in .NET actually using
C# if I remember correctly.
And it is really cool.
And actually, if
you don't know gRPC
that much, we have a couple
episodes on gRPC I think.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we do.
So episode 15-- gRPC with
Varun Talwar, a PM for gRPC.
You can go through that.
We also have a great
chat with Brandon Philips
from CoreOS in episode 43.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
That was really good.
MARK MANDEL: Which was
really, really good.
And in episode 53, we have
one of our fellow developer
advocates, Sandeep
Dinesh, comes and joins us
and talks about how he and I
put together the game Simon
and use gRPC to make it--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
Simon Says.
That's cool.
MARK MANDEL: --make it very
scalable in multiplayer
over the internet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so check it out.
I'm going to be
talking about gRPC more
often now because I did
a little demo with Go.
And it is an amazing experience.
I really like it.
MARK MANDEL: GRPC
is really nice.
No, I agree completely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
yep, check it out.
Check the episodes out.
We have all of those links
in the show notes as usual.
MARK MANDEL: So yeah, why don't
we go have a chat with Daniel
about Kubernetes?
We should probably give
a little small provider
before we jump in because
Daniel and I do nerd out
a lot about some of the
more advanced features
that have come in Kubernetes.
So if you are new
to Kubernetes, don't
feel like these are
features you have to use.
These are really just
there for if the default
things, like services
and deployments,
aren't necessarily
working for you in the way
that you need it to for
your very specific workload,
this is the configuration
options that Kubernetes
gives you to enable to tailor
it to exactly what you need.
But if you're just getting
started with Kubernetes,
maybe have a listen.
Keep it in the back of
your head in case one day
you're like, oh, there was
this thing I might need.
But if you're just getting
started, it's interesting,
but you don't have
to worry it too much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
think that is telling
that these are
features that we're not
including in Kubernetes
until version 1.6.
And many people are using
it in production already.
So very probably
you don't need them.
But if you want to
know about them,
Dan is here to tell us about it.
MARK MANDEL: Cool, so
let's go chat with them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
very happy to welcome
to the podcast Daniel Smith.
Daniel, you are a
software engineer and TL--
tech lead or team lead?
I'm not even sure--
at some random, weird
part of Kubernetes?
GKE?
Tell us about it.
What do you do?
What do you do at Google?
DANIEL SMITH: Hi.
Yeah, honestly I'm not sure
what TL stands for either.
So I'm the TL of
the API Machinery
subteam at Kubernetes.
As the Kubernetes
team has grown,
we've broken it into a bunch of
small groups, small-ish groups.
So my group is the
API Machinery group.
And our goal is to take
care of the API Machinery.
So this is the stuff,
the guts of Kubernetes,
the plumbing between
clients and servers
and between the server
and storage backend.
Making client libraries, making
the stuff that lets people
write new APIs.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, so
does that mean you're
responsible for client-go?
DANIEL SMITH: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: I've used that.
DANIEL SMITH: Oh, good.
MARK MANDEL: It was good.
I used it.
It worked well.
DANIEL SMITH: We will
try not to go over
what I think about Go's
dependency management system.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK,
so let's continue
to talk about something else.
[LAUGHTER]
So we have you today to talk
about the latest Kubernetes
version, Kubernetes 1.6.
I was going to say 1.8 because
that is Go, but no, it's 1.6.
And also we'll
talk at some point
the fact that Kubernetes
just migrated to Go 1.8.
So pretty happy about that.
So what is new in
Kubernetes 1.6?
What is the biggest
pieces of information
you think everybody should know?
DANIEL SMITH: If you look
at our documentation,
we've got a number of areas.
We've increased the scale.
Federation is to beta.
RBAC is to beta.
RBAC is a security feature.
There's some new
scheduling tricks
that you can do, a
few other things.
MARK MANDEL: Let's
talk about scale
because obviously scale
and Federation-- there seem
to be two fairly hot topics.
I believe Kubernetes now
goes up to 5,000 nodes.
Is that correct?
DANIEL SMITH: Yeah,
that's correct.
So we now enforce our--
we promise our SLO over 5,000
nodes, 5,000 node clusters.
This and the SLO is
the control plane
responds to API requests in
under a second 99% of the time.
MARK MANDEL: I was going to say.
So that's interesting.
Can you tell us actually
how that was possible?
What actually changed?
Are there changes
under the hood?
Or what happened there so
that that would be possible
so that that can happen?
DANIEL SMITH: Yeah,
the scalability team
made a bunch of changes
to make this happen.
One of the larger ones is
switching to etcd version 3.
We were previously on etcd 2.
That was actually a
pretty large effort.
That was done by
Wojciech in Poland
and my own team member, Matt,
here put in a lot of work
getting that set up.
And we had lots of help
from friends at CoreOS.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Is
it true that etcd 3--
one of the biggest changes
is that it actually
uses gRPC instead of REST?
Is that what you think
brought the performance gain?
So that's actually a detail
about the etcd client library.
DANIEL SMITH: So yes,
it does use gRPC.
But we actually got
that benefit just
by switching to
the client library.
So etcd itself scales better if
you use the version 3 format.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, nice.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
And we know Federation's a
pretty big thing in Kubernetes.
Can you tell us A, what is
Kubernetes Federation, and B,
what's new in 1.6 that we
can take advantage of now?
DANIEL SMITH: After you get
a cluster to a certain size,
it becomes very problematic if
something goes wrong, right?
So after a certain
size, it's better
to start running
multiple clusters.
You don't want the blast radius
to be too big if something
happens to your control plan.
So Federation is a way of
presenting multiple clusters
under a single control plane.
It's not new.
We've had it for a while,
but it is growing up.
And I think it went to
beta this time around.
And it can do some things
like manage pods for you,
manage replication controllers.
I think it's got services.
So you can manage multiple
clusters at the same time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How does it
look when you use Federation?
Does that mean that
kubectl has a special mode?
So when you deploy it to the
world, what does it look like?
DANIEL SMITH: Yeah, so I'm a
little bit in danger of telling
you stuff I don't know.
But you point your
Kube control--
you set your kubeconfig file to
point to the Federation control
plane.
And it's got its own
set of controllers that
just maintain configuration.
Say you want a service to
run in multiple clusters.
It looks just like the regular
config file from Kubernetes.
And there's maybe a
couple extra fields
that help it find
how many clusters
and which clusters
you want it to run.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So I guess that
since we've talked
about how you can run bigger
jobs through both larger
clusters and also many
clusters through Federation,
the next thing that
you mentioned was RBAC.
What is RBAC?
What does it stand for?
DANIEL SMITH: Ah, what
does it stand for?
How about I tell you what--
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
MARK MANDEL: Is it
role-based access control?
DANIEL SMITH: Yeah,
Yeah, that makes sense.
So basically Kubernetes
is starting to grow up.
And we're getting more
fine-grained control
over security.
When people think of
security, I think there's
two topics that that covers.
One is identity or what
we call authentication.
And the other is permissions
or what we call authorization.
And so RBAC is
about authorization.
It is a way of
specifying really, really
fine-grained permissions
on various aspects
of your clusters.
So you can specify a resource,
a verb, and an actor, a person
or a group.
And say, yes, you can do this.
No, you can't.
And this is more fine-grained
than we've had previously.
Well, I think we've
had RBAC previously,
but it's going to
beta this time around.
MARK MANDEL: So it's like
IAM but for Kubernetes
specifically.
DANIEL SMITH:
Yeah, it is exactly
like IAM for Kubernetes.
It is more fine-grained.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
So if I'm a large
organization and I
want to have certain,
maybe, senior developers who
are able to push to production.
But maybe my more
junior people I'm
going to let them push
to dev or staging.
Then I've got controls
there that I'm
able to take advantage
of to do that.
DANIEL SMITH: Yeah, absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: What's the
authorization hooks there?
Should I be able to hook
them into, I don't know,
an LDAP system or my own
custom authentication?
Or what's available there?
DANIEL SMITH: Kubernetes
supports multiple ways
of getting identity.
So LDAP will give you identity.
If you're running
a GKE installation,
then you get identity
from the Google system.
One of the things we added is
a subject access review API.
So you can actually, if you
have permission to do it,
you can actually call a
Kubernetes control plane
and ask, does this
person have permission
to do this thing
on this cluster?
MARK MANDEL: Sure, OK, cool.
So the thing that I'm actually
personally quite excited about,
and something I've been
playing with a bit,
is the advanced
scheduling stuff.
I think this is
super, super cool.
There's several
different things here.
Which one do we want
to talk about first?
So there's a whole bunch of
stuff around pod affinity
that I think is
really interesting.
Can you tell us about that?
DANIEL SMITH: I was
reading about it last night
just to make sure.
I understood it.
There's a couple of
different affinity settings.
There's affinity for nodes
and affinity for pods.
Affinity for nodes is
you'd prefer or you must.
Your pod prefers
a particular node,
or it must schedule
on a particular node.
Pod affinity is even
more interesting.
That is for situations
where you want
to be colocated with
another set of pods,
or you want to be not
colocated with a set of pods.
So pod affinity is
for when you want
to schedule taking account
of the other pods that
are on a node or in an
unavailability zone.
So it's if you have pods that
need to be scheduled together
or shouldn't be
scheduled together.
Suppose you have
workloads that need
high-bandwidth communication
between each other,
like you're doing some
machine learning something.
And you want them to be
in a network segment that
has high connectivity.
So you can set up
labels on your node
saying what your topology is.
And you can select over what
other pods have been scheduled
in this topology section.
And do I want to be scheduled
close to those pods?
Or maybe you want to spread
for disaster tolerance.
You could say, I want
to be scheduled away
from these other pods.
MARK MANDEL: So an
interesting question then.
So I can have
multiple containers
running inside a given pod.
Why would I choose
to use pod affinity
to bring other pods
together versus putting them
all together in the same pod
just with multiple containers?
What benefits do I get there?
DANIEL SMITH: I
think that's really
for very different use cases.
If you're putting multiple
things inside one pod,
you're saying that your scaling
is literally one-to-one.
If you have, I don't know, a web
frontend and a database syncer
in one pod, you are getting
exactly one of each every time
you scale up or scale down.
If you have services that
need to scale separately
but still be colocated,
like maybe you've
got one database that serves
several different web services,
the services may need to
be close to the database.
But you don't want
to scale one-to-one.
So in that case, you want
separate pods for each.
MARK MANDEL: So you're
talking about on the pod side,
you've got ways to
coordinate where
pods should be close to
each other or affinity
against each other.
But then you can also control
things on the node side
as well.
Is that right?
DANIEL SMITH: Yeah, so
there's a new beta feature--
node taints.
And I like to think of this
as the role-playing game
sense of the node is
tainted by some dark magic.
You're basically setting
a flag on the node.
And then the system
will prevent any pod
that doesn't tolerate that
flag from landing on the node.
So you could use
this for if you've
got nodes that have
GPUs or a local SSD,
and you want more normal
pods not to schedule
on those because you want to
leave those free for workloads
that really take advantage
of the unique feature.
So you could taint those
nodes with, say, GPU true.
And then only pods that
actually say, I tolerate
the GPS taint can land there.
You can use this to do
all sorts of cool stuff.
Along the same lines,
there is an alpha feature.
So the system is continuously
health checking nodes.
And after a while, it will--
if a node stops calling--
if a node stops phoning
home, the system
will set its status to unknown.
And if it doesn't come back,
it will eventually just
kick all the pods
off of the node.
You can now set some flags and
treat that event as a taint
itself.
So you can control
how long your pods
are willing to tolerate a node
that is possibly unresponsive.
MARK MANDEL: So the
question I have is
it sounds like pod
affinity and node
taints kind of do
the same things
but from different directions.
When should I choose
one over the other?
DANIEL SMITH: I think clearly if
you want your pods to do stuff
based on other
pods in the system,
then you definitely want
to use pod affinity.
If you want your pods
to schedule depending
on facts about your
nodes, then you probably
want to use node taints.
The other distinction is
taints are for keeping pods off
of nodes, and affinity is
for getting pods onto nodes.
So if you really want to set
up an exclusive relationship,
you need both.
MARK MANDEL: All right, so
the final thing on the event
schedule stuff, which
is also interesting,
is custom schedulers.
Up until this point, Kubernetes
has had the scheduler, which
has been the one true way.
But now you can
mess with it a bit.
What's that all about?
DANIEL SMITH: So
specifically this feature
is you leave the default
scheduler running,
and you startup your
own scheduler beside it.
You can set with a
field in your pods
which scheduler you would like
your pods to be scheduled by.
And you can do this,
I don't know, maybe
if you've got some special logic
that isn't covered by affinity
or taints or threading.
If you've got something
custom that needs to happen,
you can write a scheduler
that does that for you.
And then you can have your
pods go through that scheduler
instead of the default one.
MARK MANDEL: And
I think I saw one
of our teammates, Ian Lewis--
he'll probably write a blog
post for the Kubernetes blog.
I will link to it
in the show notes--
wherein I think I saw-- yeah,
he wrote a custom scheduler
in Bash.
So there doesn't seem to
be a limit on the language
that you can write your
custom schedulers in.
Is that correct?
DANIEL SMITH: One of the
best things about Kubernetes,
I think, is just the fact
that our APIs are truly open.
There's no secret API.
All of the stuff that the
default system components do
is stuff you can do.
And you can do it through
the Go client library.
You can do it through
Kube control and Bash.
The system doesn't
really care what's
on the other end of the API.
We're starting to come out with
libraries and other languages.
There's a pretty full-featured
Python library now.
So yeah, you can
write it in Bash.
I wouldn't recommend it, but if
that's what floats your boat.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I had a question regarding
not scheduling anymore.
But sometimes you want
to scale your cluster.
You need more volumes.
You need storage.
The only way to create
this is either you
create it by
yourself or you want
to create it automatically.
And I think in 1.4, dynamic
provisioning was added.
And there's something
new about it,
but I don't know what it is.
What's going on with
dynamic storage provision?
DANIEL SMITH: So I think this
feature is pretty awesome.
Let me give some
background on the storage
system in Kubernetes.
Because a large
part of Kubernetes
is workload portability, right?
We want to be able to write
your application targeted
at Kubernetes and then run it
in multiple cloud environments.
Now it turns out that cloud
environments don't all
do storage volumes the same way.
So to get around this,
we have a concept
which is persistent volume.
And we have another concept
called persistent volume claim.
And the idea is you
write your workload
to talk to a persistent
volume claim.
And you allocate
persistent volumes
from the cloud provider.
So if you go to a
different cloud provider,
all that has to
change is the logic
that's producing the volumes.
Your application
doesn't even notice.
And so what's new
here is that there's
a storage class
that's introduced,
a storage class object.
And that is basically a
thing that can automatically
produce persistent volumes.
So it frees cluster
administrators
from having to do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So I'm curious about you
mentioned the storage claim.
Could that be seen
as basically the API
that someone needs to satisfy
to be able to provide storage
volumes for Kubernetes?
Which means that basically
there's one for Google Cloud.
But also if you want to run
it on other cloud providers
or even on premise, that's what
you should be implementing?
DANIEL SMITH: So if you
wanted to port Kubernetes
to a particular
cloud environment,
the thing that you want to
produce is a controller logic.
So I haven't looked at the
dynamic storage provisioning
feature at code level.
But there must be a controller.
And if you wanted to port to
a different cloud environment,
you would write
an implementation
of that controller
Call that would
look for unsatisfied claims
against a storage class.
And then you'd select
the appropriate volume
settings, size, et cetera,
from your cloud environment.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Is there any other--
those seem to be the
big highlights that I
think we've covered there.
But are there any
other little things
that have also been added
that are cool and interesting?
DANIEL SMITH: Some
under-the-hood stuff, I think,
is probably worth mentioning.
A bunch of work has been done
on something called a Container
Runtime Interface.
And this effort is probably
not super user-visible,
but it will make some things
easier for us in the future.
And basically the
idea is kubelet,
which is the node agent, has
two responsibilities basically.
On one side, it's talking
to the Kubernetes API
and getting workloads and
reporting back, et cetera.
And on the other side, it's
talking to the container
runtime, which is
usually Docker,
and is starting
containers, stopping them.
So the Container Runtime
Interface's effort
is to split this down the middle
and let the container runtime
part of that be out of process
to kubelet so that it's easier
for people to implement that.
Kubelet can focus on correctly
implementing the Kubernetes
API.
Another cool thing
that kubelet is doing--
I'm excited about
this because it
is fixing a longstanding
issue that we've had
sometimes-- is kubelet
is now declaring
space for system daemons.
I call this feature
node allocatable.
And the idea is the
system components,
like kubelet itself,
Docker, other daemons
that are running on the
system, they take up some RAM.
They take up some CPU.
And if you don't take
that into account,
the scheduler will stuff
so much stuff onto the node
that it will go out of memory
and start killing things.
So it's pretty cool to have
this put in to the node stats
so that the scheduler
can take account
to this and not overload nodes.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Now I think we've covered all
the stuff that's pretty much
available and in beta.
But we've had some new alpha
features as well that--
I know we don't necessarily
support out-of-the-box without
clicking some
checkboxes and saying,
this is fine if you
set yourself on fire.
Do you want to talk about--
DANIEL SMITH: Yeah, you can make
an alpha cluster, but you can--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
It's all on you.
But yeah, what new alpha
features are available
right now?
DANIEL SMITH: So one thing I'm
excited about is out-of-tree
cloud providers, which
is we're splitting our--
there's multiple control plane
components in Kubernetes.
And one of them is called
controller manager.
That groups all of the
various controllers
that are running the system.
Kubernetes does this "build
out of this control loop"
pattern where we have
these components that
basically are doing one thing.
They're watching [INAUDIBLE]
said, it wants five pods.
They're looking at the cluster.
You only have four.
So it'll make a new one.
The whole system is built
out of this control loop.
We're splitting
that binary up so
that the ones that are specific
and married to a cloud provider
are in a different binary.
So that you can run the standard
controller manager binary
and also the one appropriate
for your cloud environment.
If you were doing a bare metal
installation or something,
you could just take a
look at that skeleton
and see what it provides and
write your own implementation.
Another thing I'm excited
about, which is alpha support,
is GPUs.
So we handle GPUs as
resources on nodes now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Could
you tell me more about it?
What does it look like to
say, I want to use GPUs.
Let's say there's someone that
wants to do video game stuff,
and they need video
rendering of stuff.
How does it look?
DANIEL SMITH: I haven't played
with that particular feature,
so I am probably not
the best person to ask.
I thought it was targeted more
towards machine learning--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, interesting.
DANIEL SMITH: --folks.
It probably also works for
people who need to do renders.
But I think it's
targeted towards--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's a good point.
DANIEL SMITH:
--machine learning.
MARK MANDEL: So more exposure
of the CUDA stuff and that stuff
and NVIDIA cards and
things like that.
DANIEL SMITH: Yeah,
I don't know that we
go into that level of detail.
I think it's just the
kubelet notes that, hey, I've
got this many GPUs available.
And then the scheduler
can see that pods
want one, two, a
few GPUs, and it
can track that as a resource.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
One more question
I wanted to ask you
is do you know a
little bit about how
was it to migrate to Go 1.8.
Was it an easy thing?
DANIEL SMITH: Yeah, so we
did just get to Go 1.8.
I think we got there yesterday,
maybe the day before.
So Kubernetes 1.6 is
still built with 1.7.
But on head, we are on Go 1.8.
And it seems cool so far.
I've been running it on my
personal system for a while.
I'm excited to see more.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
We are running
out of time a bit.
But what's on the roadmap
for Kubernetes going forward?
I saw there have
been drops on 1.7
for alpha releases and stuff.
But what stuff can we see
coming down the pipeline?
DANIEL SMITH: I'll just
focus on what I and my team
are working on.
I think we've got some
cool stuff planned.
The things that get me
excited in Kubernetes
are the things that make
it easier for the ecosystem
to develop and for us to
get more components that
interoperate with Kubernetes.
And so in that vein, we're
working on API aggregation.
This is the idea that
you can take your own API
and aggregate it seamlessly
with the Kubernetes API.
So we have various
folks in the ecosystem,
like OpenShift,
who basically are
operating something that's very,
very similar to Kubernetes.
But it's actually a fork
if you look under the hood.
They have very
painful merges when
Kubernetes increments version.
So the idea here
is the people who
want to add this sort of API
can run it on top of Kubernetes
instead of operating a fork.
And this should make it
much easier to add APIs.
You should be able
to add multiple APIs
in the same cluster.
So yeah, this is what
I'm looking forward to.
MARK MANDEL: Is that linked
to third-party resources?
Is that in that
same vein as people
who want to add their own
resources to Kubernetes
and make it do special things?
DANIEL SMITH: Yeah,
it is similar.
And this is a really
hot topic last quarter.
If you poke around the
API Machinery SIG docs,
you'll find one that I put
out there that was comparing
and contrasting the two.
I think the short story
is that Kubernetes
needs both third-party
resources and API
aggregation going forward.
Third-party resources-- the
target audience there is it's
really easy to get
something up and running.
It doesn't take a lot of effort.
It works with Kube
control already.
So it's low effort, easy to use,
not necessarily full-featured.
And the idea with
aggregation, API aggregation,
is a little bit
more heavyweight.
Probably you're only
going to do this
if you really want to
fundamentally alter or add
some really fundamental
API concept.
We're going to offer a library.
You'd compile.
You'd run your own API server.
You make an entry in
the aggregation API.
And then that would get
integrated with Kube control.
And if you do things
that way, you'll
get all the power
of the API systems
so you can do all the
fancy validation you want.
You can write super custom
admission controller.
You can do strange
defaulting, anything you like.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
I think that we're pretty
out of time by now.
So thank you so much
for taking the time
to tell us a little bit about
all the cool things that
come in with Kubernetes 1.6.
It was very interesting.
DANIEL SMITH: Cool.
Thanks for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
thank you so much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So thanks, Daniel,
for such an interesting
conversation.
There was a lot of those
things that I'm not
sure I completely
understood what
they were for
because like there's
really advanced stuff there.
If you've felt that
way, do not fear.
That's normal I guess.
But thanks.
Yeah, thanks.
It was really,
really interesting,
and it makes you think about
all of those little features
that probably you will not need.
But the day you'll need
them, they're there.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So why don't we have a chat
about the question of the week?
I thought this would be a
bit interesting if we just
talked a little bit about.
So you create a Google
Cloud Platform project.
What's the first thing you do?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let
me say my things first.
MARK MANDEL: Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
normally what I do
is I create my
projects all the time
from the console, from
console.cloud.google.com.
MARK MANDEL: I do the same.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then what
I do is I go to my terminal,
and I do gcloud init to set
up all the configuration
so whenever I do
anything from gcloud,
it will be actually
referring to that.
And I do this partly because I
have three different accounts
linked to my gcloud.
So I want to make sure that
I do what I do in the project
that I'm trying to.
Otherwise, I would get
errors, and it's annoying.
MARK MANDEL: Do you
use configurations?
Or do you just read reauth
on the same account?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
do not use configurations.
I just do reauth.
And it's very easy.
It works pretty well.
There's a product
manager for gcloud here.
I wish that I could
have directory-dependent
configurations.
MARK MANDEL: That would be nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Consider
it as a feature request
from the podcast.
But yeah, just gcloud init,
and that works pretty well.
And then, well,
right after that,
I'm going to go to
the console again.
And it seems very
often what I'm doing
is I'm going to be running
somehow Compute Engine
instances.
And you need to
activate that API.
What I do is I go to
the Compute Engine tab.
And then just by clicking there,
the API starts activating.
That takes a couple of minutes.
So it's always the
first thing you do.
You don't pay for
having me activate it.
Sometimes I deploy
in App Engine,
and I still will
activate the API.
MARK MANDEL: Just by habit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, just
because that's what I do.
But yeah, that's pretty much it.
And then check that
the billing account
is set up and all
of these things
so I can actually start working
on the project directly.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So I'm very
similar to you in that I set up
my project through
console.cloud.google.com
strangely enough.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You don't
use the deployment manager
for that?
MARK MANDEL: So you could.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You could.
I know.
That's why--
DANIEL SMITH: You can.
I haven't played with that yet.
But I may one day soon.
In fact, maybe I will.
Maybe I will do that now
that I think about it
because I have a few steps.
So the first thing
I do, actually,
is I make sure I have multiple
owners on the account.
I start with my email
address, and then I
have a secondary
email address that I
use to make sure there are
multiple emails on the account
just in case.
Always a good thing to have just
in case one account-- something
happens to it.
And then you can still have
access to your projects.
Ideally multiple
people is a good idea,
but yeah, multiple
owners is always good.
And then basically-- this
is not really a step but--
make sure that the emails--
the owners on my accounts--
I make sure those
are email accounts
that I actually look
at on a regular basis
because if anything goes
bad with your project--
In fact, we had a conversation
with the abuse team
at one point.
If anything bad happens
with your project,
say, somebody compromises one
of your systems or something
like that happens, then that's
the email address you're
going to get a message out to.
So you want to receive those.
Those are really important
because otherwise you
can get your project shut
down, and that would be sad.
And that would make
you very, very sad.
So definitely I like
having multiple owners
and making sure that those
emails are monitored.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Going back
to the topic you were talking
about abuse and support.
Yeah, reading those
emails is really important
because when you receive
one of those emails,
they're actually important,
and you need to answer them.
There's two episodes where we
cover a little bit about this
and the best practices
on how to make sure
that your projects are
following the terms of services
and all of these things.
There's episode 47
with cloud abuse.
And we had Swati Kulshreshth
and Emeka Okonkwo.
And then on episode 24, we
also had Terrance Shepherd
talking about Google
Cloud Platform support.
Yeah, we covered all
the little things
that you might want to do.
Especially I'd say that
the biggest piece of advice
is make sure those
emails do not go
to some account nobody reads.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, don't
send them to dev/null.
Don't do that.
That's bad.
Well, Francesc, it's wonderful
talking with you again.
Where are you going to
be in the next few weeks?
What are you up to?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So next week,
I will be here in San Francisco
for Gopherfest that's
going to be on Monday.
And after that, I
will be on my way
to some really quick holidays.
And by the end of
the month, I will
go to Buenos Aires
for the OnBoard event.
That's going to be pretty cool.
And next I will
be going to QCon.
I'm actually very
excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I have this
video, Go Tooling in Action,
that's pretty popular.
And I'm making a
workshop out of that.
And I'll be running
it on QCon New York.
I'm pretty excited about that.
That'll be at the end of June.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So next week
I will be off to Sweden
for Nordic Games Conference,
which should be lots of fun.
I'll make a shoutout.
I'm not going to be
there, but if anyone's
in San Francisco on
Saturday, the second part
of the Playcrafting and
Extra Life Game Jam is there.
GameFest, which is this weekend.
And basically it's a
free event for 24 hours.
You can go play games.
They're going to be streaming
stuff, just basically raising
money for kids in hospitals.
So super, super cool.
And it's Launchpad Space
here in San Francisco.
I'll make sure
we'll link to that.
And then I go on some holidays
for a bit as well actually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
I heard that there's this
little event, Google I/O.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
That is coming up, isn't it?
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
will not be attending.
MARK MANDEL: I will
not be attending.
I will be in Sweden.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
will not be attending.
But I know that many of
you might be attending.
Let us know how it goes.
We're going to be interviewing
some people about some things
that might be happening
at Google I/O.
And you'll have an
episode on that after.
MARK MANDEL: That
was very vague.
I like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
It's very secret.
Nobody knows what's going on.
MARK MANDEL: And what's great
is we could slot in anybody,
and no one would know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
Thanks, Mark, so much for
such an amazing episode.
I feel like this
episode without you
would have been way harder
because I really did not know
what we were talking about.
So thank you so much.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you to you, Francesc.
And thank you very much to
everyone who's listening.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See
[MUSIC PLAYING]